I was recently home in Boston and my
mother my mother Irena referred to the
singer Celine Dion listen to me now she
referred to the singer Celine Dion as
Salaam T Shawn I honestly don't know why
we're not all doing backflips right now
salon Dijon was said to me in a room
with air in it I heard it remembered it
and brought it to the show that is a
gift
I haven't even added anything it's like
a cat bringing a dead bird it's a
treasure and it wasn't like this it
wasn't like Peter who's that singer
french-canadian I don't know so Angie
John I don't know what's her name I
don't know salon is that it salon Dijon
add it up it wasn't like that it was
like this Peter your father got me
tickets to my favorite recording artist
salon Dijon just an expensive mustard
rinse of a performer booth
I love salon I hope she plays my
favorite song from my favorite movie big
boat iceberg that's my favorite movie
starring my favorite actor Leonardo -
pizza place he is a dream here there
under the stairs I love the lyrics none
of those are the lyrics mom so I don't
know if you can tell by my overall vibe
I am a friendly fellow kind of guy that
likes to get to the airport a couple
hours early get a few white wines and me
and start telling old people they still
got it that's a high five and babies
that sort of thing
I don't feel like I belong in comedy
people going out drinking slippery
American cocktails having sex after I
don't belong in the nightclub scene look
at me look this face doesn't how you
doing fixed your taillight while you
were sleeping no charge
that's I don't belong in a comedy club I
like to think that there are millions
and millions of different universes each
slightly different from the last and
this universe the one we're all in
currently is the only one where I'm not
a youth pastor does that resonate with
you I shouldn't be on a fancy stage
right now I should be in a carpeted
gymnasium with an acoustic guitar with a
rainbow strap just like
who wants to rap about the Lord let's do
this let's get some testimonies going
Tyler I love those testes buddy break
out those testes but no one will tell me
why that's funny yeah corny guy I always
like doing something silly up top this
is a guy telling his Latino friend but
their soccer team finally broke their
losing streak okay guy telling his
Latino friend but their soccer team
finally broke their losing streak
[Applause]
we've won one watt
one we won one we finally won one one
where were you when we won one one we
finally won one one one is what we won
one one is what we won it was one two
one for the longest time one then we won
one one penalty kicks
if that doesn't unlock the safe where
you keep your joy
maybe lube up the dial a little bit just
a little bit for yourself that's we're
having a good time as the worst thing to
do when you're actually having a good
time is to declare it I do that all the
time if I'm at a party and I we are
having a fun time I'll go oh man fun
with friends not anymore you just ruined
it actually teach you guys the worst
thing you can say do you guys want to
learn the worst thing you can say I
figured it out if you're at a party and
you actually are having a fun time wait
for there to be a low in your little
horseshoe of friends
statistically every 11 minutes then just
look at them and go oh man this party is
McDonald's
I'm loving it that's it that's the worst
thing you can say feel how you feel
right now violated that joke changes
your core temperature the feeling of
hearing that joke is the feeling of
getting hit in the face with a living
lobster that's what that joke feels like
and everyone falls word I don't care how
smart you are like this part is
McDonald's what what are you what do you
mean but what does he mean by that
what do you mean by that sir I'm loving
it you you sir everyone falls
for you have this this is a tool in your
tool belt now you didn't know you were
gonna leave better than you came if
you're on a date you just don't give a
about the date you knew right away
you're like no sabotage the date wait
for a lull and just look at them and be
like oh man this date is McDonald's
then there's a timing to it it's a three
count or two dry swallows look they're
gone they are not there they're not
there when you come back
you